[Music]
so what do you do I am a businessman
nice
what's your favorite crypto
I don't use no so you seem like a
Bitcoin type yeah one day one day and
you jumped on an old guy yeah because he
he was touching his friend yeah
[Music]
haven't seen you in like ages nice to
meet you hi what's up three Jasmine
Jasmine
nice to meet you sorry
I was actually I was gonna DM you I saw
you posted on your story uh saying we're
looking for more girls to no way you saw
I was gonna DM you I was going to be
like you come
I was gonna be like quick home no
because I work with pearl so um
recruiting so she was like jazz just
calm I'm Gonna Get You new for now so I
ran literally got dressed did my makeup
in the Uber
it looks great thank you well how do you
like working for pearl I haven't been a
very good worker for like two months wow
what are you what are you doing I just
took a break from a lot of things
um to do what
just work focus on modeling and I don't
know just anything social I took a break
from it was just
too much modeling is pretty social yeah
but it's like if I get a paid booking I
will take that
I don't know what type of modeling do
you do yeah I'm a professional hair
model what can I see yeah they're like
really
really dainty yeah they're like really
skinny long slender fingers I can see
you holding a shampoo bottle yeah some
people always make
so why did you need to take a break from
everything
um I don't know I just I was going
through something with someone you're
going through a breakup
yeah
I was seeing someone so I just kind of
took a break and I was seeing them for
like almost every day so I didn't really
have time to do much else can do that
yeah I know and a relationship becomes
your life that's when I know when it
because when it fails and it hurts much
more because then you just lost
everything that was going on yeah what
can I ask uh what would happen
um
so I I in my head I thought we were like
together we were really good and then
um he
I took a break from a lot of things I
was doing I stream on Twitch I'm a gamer
I stream on Tick Tock I'm like always
doing something and I just really wanted
to spend a lot of time with him I know
that shouldn't be the way he's just
still focus on your career this and that
um well
um yeah I thought we were really good
and then like recently
I found out that um he cheated on you
yeah
that I've heard a common theme with uh
the other girls they've left
relationships because their boyfriend
cheated on them yeah but so let me guess
and I don't want to talk about this if
it's making you feel it seems like it
was recent right yeah it's quite recent
so you you felt like your self-worth
went down like you felt worthless
afterwards right I
not so much
so much relief in my system and it was
like you're glad it ended no glad that
it ended
kind of I think because I think but I
just had as soon as I found out because
I actually found the girl and had a
two-hour conversation with her about
what happened
yeah and you guys are friends now me and
the girl which is cool I don't really
need to be friends with her but you know
like you just get that ultimate girl
connection but I actually went to
apologize to her because I thought I
ruined him and her friendship I thought
they were friends I went I'm sorry if I
caused the problem between you and this
person she's like babe I was there last
week like he flew me over for a week
blah blah blah oh no yeah and I actually
have big relief left my sis like my body
and I was like okay now I'm not I know
I'm not going crazy but the problem was
I wasn't really that mad that he cheated
it was more so the fact of him trying to
make me seem like a crazy like a crazy
person try making me seem psycho yeah he
was like he's at work gasoline all the
time so you thought he was cheating and
he called you crazy yeah because yeah
I've done that you've done that done
that I've done that she would do that no
no no I'm honest I'm honest I'm open I
don't lie about
um
having other women because that's just
what I I'm straight up about that from
the jump now because I don't have to go
through that back and forth and hiding
my phone and maybe that's one of them
calling me right now but that's just
yeah I just I like to be straight I
don't think there's any point I don't
think like a real high value man would
have to hide any of that that's that's
what I'm saying if I was his priority
and his number one he said like you know
I didn't care about any of the girl I
think if you would have been okay with
it if he wasn't lying
I for me truth on honesty is
everything like I said it was a relief
when I found out because I actually got
some honesty and some truth from someone
even though it wasn't from him so like
you know like if you're dating a certain
type of man
I think you should expect it if yeah you
should expect it I didn't expect it from
him but I feel like you should expect it
but I think from a man point of view I
don't think you should lie to the woman
that you
not obviously you might lie to your side
chicks or the girls you're seeing but to
your woman you're spending all your time
with them you had invested so much time
into this relationship that it must have
been yeah
yeah he was he was very special to me
but um I'm very cool with it now I'm
just you know like you seem like you
bounce back you look very you don't look
like it's holding you back you look
great yeah it was I hadn't like a rough
spot like a couple of weeks ago remember
that you cried it out you watch the
Netflix you ate the chocolate you drank
the wine yeah bad mouth them to your
friends and you call them no I never I
don't really like to talk to my friends
about some stuff of course there's some
certain friends I would talk to but I
prefer to keeping it to myself because I
know exactly what they're gonna say dump
his ass like leave him completely block
him yep
he's not worth it but I'm like
you know he's this type of guy I just
wish he was honest with me and didn't
make me seem like a crazy psychopath
but yeah so you so you um you're making
me feel bad now for for doing this to
past girls yeah but you must know
where's like you must see their
responses of when they find out yeah I
know I've definitely yeah
lying is it makes people does make
people go crazy and then they'll call
you crazy for a thick and they it's just
this Loop of I know activity it's the
worst like if you're you can't not make
a girl seem crazy it's the worst thing
you can do sir because she already is
crazy and now you're making her crazier
you're already emotional by Nature like
why go and yeah you're toxic this that I
don't know so how old are you I'm 24
I'll do you you're 24 yeah
only I'm 23. you're one year older than
me why did that you just got so stunned
by that I lit I thought you were like
35. what the
I literally for you it's one like way
above 35 yeah I look 35. you don't
really maybe a little bit it's not an
insult I I like how like I only like all
the guys I only go after them yeah I can
be 35 for you you'll be 35 for me I'll
be 36 for you then I'll be I'll be 47.
maybe 47. I'll be 85 85. okay
I'll be a grandpa okay anything so what
do you want me to be for you
I just want you to be you I like your
hair I like your personality I like your
honesty I think you're very beautiful
thank you and I think that you will
value the good things that make people
good people because I said I that
cheating isn't the worst thing no no
because well obviously that's part of it
but no it's it's the fact that you value
honesty and truth I really do I could
tell that you're a good-hearted person
and the fact that somebody wasn't good
to you and how much well how that hurt
you in the past but you're over it that
made you that shows that you have a pure
heart which I think is is a valuable
thing to my heart is for EPL and people
take advantage yeah that's what happens
when you're
manipulative people take advantage of
that but it seems like you're so
optimistic which is good it kind of
worries me that you're kind of young but
I I don't know anything I'm older than
you and you're calling me young
women are insane this is why women are
crazy I'm literally older than you and
you're calling me a baby
but you are a baby what does that make
you a fetus
toddler is that younger than a baby no
it's always that that makes no sense
wait so how then your ex must have been
much older than you yes that's 57. yeah
there you go but how did that work out
that's what I'm saying so I think maybe
my mindset's wrong on only dating older
guys or talking to older guys maybe I
think and I am an older guy yeah but
you're not I am but I'm literally older
than you which makes me an older guy
okay the women are are so and you know
what's funny too when you get to 35 you
know what you're gonna say you're gonna
see guys like Leonardo DiCaprio who's
like 41 dating 18 year olds and then
they call them creepy and then they say
that why would he do why but Lee he
should be with so they will women the
same women who who call me a bait for
call guys older than older than them
babies will then go and shame Leo
because they're not 18 anymore so there
must be something creepy or weird Leo he
dates girls and they're younger than 20
and he's broken up with them and they've
turned 20.
25. yeah that's crazy don't you think
how is it not crazy to call me a baby
even though I'm older than you isn't
that not equally crazy
because it's not is that even crazy that
he has a preference he has a type of
girl he's open and honest about it if
you want the same age Gap you were 23
and he's 37 that's what
um that's 14 years yeah he's 14 years
older than a lot of these girls and they
called him creepy the whole time
so when it's on the reverse like that's
people shame men for their standards but
when women have the exact same
expectation and standard it's just seen
as normal no I don't I don't have a
problem with a man having a standard you
know if someone has you know a lot of
people have their type nowadays and
people get offended by a woman who like
a man that's six foot and they complain
I'm like but it's her it's her standard
preference it's her preference so is it
creepy if I want to date girls when
they're 18 in virgins
I don't think it's creepy but I don't
think it's mature of you just do that
like if you if you know how valuable a
virgin is right why would you go in date
of Virgin if you're not trying to marry
her and take her virginity
like it would be very immature of you to
go and date a virgin because you're
trying to take so am I more mature if I
date a single mother
no you're not what so how I don't know I
think it requires a certain you
definitely have to be very mature to
date a single mother and look after her
kid for example
but I don't think it's right for you to
go and date a version though and how
valuable that virgin is if you haven't
got the right intentions for her
if you're trying to marry her and you
look babe we're going to get married you
know I'll take your vision to you the
day we get married then I would say
go ahead go dating most of these girls
don't even want to aren't even dating to
marry you anyway they're 18. most of
them just want to have a good time so
why do you want to date why do you want
a date in 18 year old virgin if you know
that they're not trying to marry because
it's my preference
is your preference hypothetically so
it's literally just your preference
because they're young and they're a
virgin and they haven't been traumatized
yet but there's nothing wrong with
traumatize if a woman can handle herself
she can handle her there's nothing wrong
to you but you see you see how you're I
was the craziest do you see how you're
applying your standards to someone else
to a man's preference I'm not no matter
what it is even if you think that
traumatized is fine if that's his
preference you should just let it go
just like the six feet or if I'm a baby
there shouldn't be any judgments about
maturity there shouldn't be any
judgments about what you should or
should not be doing if that's the
preference that's a preference we see
how men can't have the same standards
that women have
they can we should continue this
conversation
yeah that's the red light oh does that
mean it's over okay it wasn't to be more
romantic that was quick
sorry that was that wasn't that quick
that was uh the same as all the others
is that over that's a good thing yeah
nice meeting you
are we continuing this can we I don't
know yeah
okay bye that was a good one because
um
I enjoyed the conversation and the the
dialogue some people criticize me for
this type of tactic when I go on dates I
kind of have the this debate style and I
like question girls and they they feel
interrogated I think it makes for
a more interesting conversation because
I get bored just running game all the
time and saying nice things uh I would
not recommend other people like ask
about previous relationships or ask
about her ex-boyfriend but I'm just I've
been on so many dates today I'm just
like trying to keep myself interested
because I know I have a lot more to go
through that was a good conversation
that had me engaged but it's We're not
gonna work me and her not gonna work she
called me a baby and I'm older than her
do you see how modern women think when I
was 35 in her head when I said my age
I went down like five notches in her
head she's like Oh I thought you were
like 35.
oh you're having a beanie
started patronizing me started
emasculating me because what you don't
want your man to be a baby but I'm
literally older than her and I'm a baby
can't please you would respond well if I
said what are you saying fam yeah
Oh serious about me
so you're gonna lie to the father of
your children no I'm just gonna say
a lot right now yeah you woke up an hour
ago I know
well